so damn what an episode this was this is
the the southern Raiders and this is a
one where Zuko is taking Katara to find
the person not just the tribe not the
army but the person who killed her
mother as we know she's carried a lot of
anger and pain over this even more than
Sokka
and it man what a it a lot going on here
a lot of emotional weight that is
extremely difficult to convey in
whatever 24 23 minutes and they do it
quite well there's one or two moments
where it felt maybe a touch roster like
oh maybe could waited you know half a
minute longer on this but it you only
have so much time you have this time
limit I totally get it
I'm impressed they got they got done
what they got done and they got the
emotional impact that they needed it's
also very good episode for the oh I
don't know her name oh no oh I'm gonna
look it up Mae Whitman that's her name
hopefully I'm saying that one right um
anytime there's like I really I really
really wanna give Greg to someone they
give a really good dramatic performance
and wants it the name so uh Mae Whitman
I believe I'm saying that right is the
actor's name the the person who plays
Katara uh and what really struck me
about the performance here is that the
strongest moments seem to be the the
very quiet the very short moments like
the one that I think the one that hit me
the strongest was when she tells the
story about what happened to her mother
and when Zuko is listening to aces your
mother was a brave woman and she just
says I know and just the way she said
those two words so effective and there's
a lot of moments like that where maybe
it's just a short sentence or you know
even like a breath or something like
that they were just they hit the perfect
spots I mean they were so effective
they're not the generic you know sir
wobbly voice I know or the strong I know
or something like that it was just the
right medium uh so just big kudos to her
on this performance I mean I really
really think she nailed it um
and the interesting thing about this you
know you got or what's the other mode
the other moment that really mu you just
sort of step back holy is when is
sokka's say you know she's about to take
off and socket saying look you you
should let this really consume you this
is bad I mean she was my mother too and
she says something along the lines of
then you didn't love her as much I mean
just like oh like that you know
family big shifts like holy hey
this is heavy heavy stuff man and it's
done so well and it all comes together
the return of the blood bending as soon
as she saw the guy that she thinks is
the killer and starts doing the blood
bending again I just went holy so
many moments in this episode where I
just was saying that over and over holy
holy um and and it has the
build-up for we known throughout these
episodes the build-up for it was so
where this episode starts off as her
wanting to trust suco it transforms into
something else I mean it's supposed to
at the start it's supposed to be about
Zuko's redemption in her eyes but it
turns into something else and it flows
into that so beautifully and so
perfectly uh and it's just uh very
nicely done um I see the other
interesting thing that I said that
before I say that laughs er interesting
thing when she confronts the killer and
you kind of know she's not gonna do it
in fact you very much know she's not
gonna do it
um but you don't quite know why and
originally I thought maybe he was gonna
have transformed into a nice guy maybe
or a quiet guy or something like that
and she couldn't do it I like to serve
went the other route where he was very
pathetic and he was you know take my
mother instead
but he wasn't I mean he was like as she
said there was nothing there but wasn't
a sense that like he's so evil he's so
mean and coolest I he's just this
pathetic thing
and he had this power and now it's gone
and he discovers that that wasn't what
he should have been working at he should
have been working out what the rest of
characters working on that would work on
himself and oh it's fascinating that she
could not still forgive him uh and
that's an interesting area to leave off
that you know sort of in the perfect
kid's world lessons story thing if they
will whatever that is I just said um
that she would forgive him and she
forgives Zuko which is great but she and
she doesn't kill the guy but she cannot
forgive him and that's a very again
that's that's probably good to leave in
there because this you take a long time
to develop these characters and she
crosses one hurdle and the hurdle is not
killing him and not getting revenge
essentially but the other hurdle the
major one she can't and it's very
possible she never will and that's just
one of life's truths you know it's a
tough truth and you try to fight against
as much as you can but it it can be one
of those truths it can just be that way
so I'm glad this show does have the
balls to say eight this is this can
happen you know there can sometimes be
no forgiveness and we're not saying it's
right but sometimes it's just gonna
happen um and I think people who go
through anything like what this
character has gone through will probably
identify and I again I don't think
they're saying it's right but I think
the show is trying to say that it
understands it gets it and that it's not
an easy transition um especially in one
episode I get the feeling she did
forgive him in one episode it might be a
little too rushed a little too you know
role the happy music and the end credits
and and it's not quite that easy so I
really liked that they did that as a
again a very gutsy choice there uh and
the ending here too with Zuko again I
I'm not
sure how this is going but the ending
with Zuko asking or telling Aang if you
believe violence is never the answer
what are you gonna do with my father and
leaving it there very good area to stop
um I'm one of those people who whether
they be surprised or not I'm on those
people who does not believe violence is
never the answer but with that said
don't get in your mouth I think it's
always the answer or majority of time
the answer I don't think it is I do not
like violence
I think violence is the act somebody
makes when they cannot find a
non-violent route to take either they're
not strong enough or they're not smart
enough and you know I think we're all
guilty of that at some point whether
we're children or adults or whatever um
but saying violence is never the answer
is like any other extreme that I think
majority of time there's going to be
exceptions to the rule uh you know world
war ii violence is never the answer well
with that kind of the day for the world
you know fighting bag their self-defense
there's people who are gonna try it and
sometimes you have to find you know the
best way around it um you know and it is
gonna be that in order to save yourself
you know so preservation so I like the
fact that they're addressing that that
we have this very difficult ground the
very difficult subject where I come up
to is that for a kid who constantly uses
violence to I sort of was thrown off of
in ways like violence is never the
answer I'm like show all the big ass
action sequences you know just because
you haven't killed anybody technically
doesn't mean that you know you haven't
really hurt the Buller injure them or
even during some of the big battles race
fighting the ships what they all got out
okay I mean it I don't know but in
self-defense I understand and again I I
agree with the idea that it should only
be done it's like war it should only be
done if there's no other option if you
know it the only reason you do is is to
get to a point where you don't have to
do it you know the same thing with
violence only reason you would do
violence's get to a point we don't have
to have violent self-defense essentially
so I I really don't know what they're
going to do
in order for him to fight the Fire Lord
it's very it's like a big question mark
for me it's like I really don't know now
that they introduced this that Aang is
really asking himself well wait if I
believe this philosophy how can I do
this I'm really curious I don't know if
he's gonna appease to his humanity or if
he's gonna find some way to entrap him
like I can't see it trapping a Praia
needs more closure but I I don't know in
a way that will also get closure for the
show or find a way where he forgives him
and lets him go but then the fire King
deuce himself in or maybe Zuko kills him
I don't know III don't know I'm very
fascinated to find out now that they've
introduced this so yeah I'm trying to
think what else uh good only thing you
can think of is really good funny moment
from Sokka and the opening when Sookie's
trying to sneak in and then Zuko goes in
instead and he has a rose in his mouth
that as another make me laugh hard stain
um and also also a strong opening with
their just lying down they're all
happiness to Austin just a bomb flies up
ships are coming it's just a big freakin
action scene that's a really good action
scene with the Azula on the ship and I'm
having that great big fight again
another great delivery with um from
Dante Basco when she sees when he sees
her falling and she just says this line
she's not gonna make it and it's just
such a confused emotion he's getting out
it's both this wow this could be the end
of our problems but also I'm losing my
sister like just not knowing how to say
that light how to express it and then of
course when she saved it of course she
makes a baby which is great delivery and
a great line to so uh a very strong
episode a very difficult episode to pull
off in the time frame like I said maybe
one or two times I wish they could have
gone longer but they can't I mean they
just can't and it's it's a shame but you
gotta work within your limitations and
for these limitations they do an
unbelievably good job so again a big big
respect to the voice actors in this one
and the writing
just very very nicely done and just very
very well balanced so um yeah that's
about it I will see you next be log